hi guys today I'm gonna visit with my
friend it's that and we figured because
it's Halloween we're going to do a
competition to see who can make the most
scary Halloween okay we got our cupcake
and here is the treats we're gonna
decorate them with
so let's excited start with making it
way hmm
one of these zombie Bacon's what kind of
creepy looking do it I will as well Oh
copy haha no I did want to do it what
are you making a mouse and I'm making a
cauldron what are you making
I am making this eye ball I think a ball
of I know a cupcake of I yours looks
very much fun to eat if you did a
wrapper off the I suppose you might show
oh no I was talking to my own is your
eye a good conversation this pudding is
a very good guys it looks creepy blood
if someone walked and please dead the
same won't and boot I'll smooth it down
oh no I did another one cool
scariest cupcake ever poo cupcake if a
zombie apocalypse happened uh-huh cause
you've got somebody baking here you know
if you could actually eat zombie bacon
like something's were real and you
killed a zombie and you made bacon
promote some sort of meat and it's the
only thing that you have left to eat ran
out of all your tin food you know all
the vegetables and stuff a dying or you
can eat your friends because the dead
zombie meat obviously you don't know
whether you're gonna turn into a zombie
if you eat it that's true if everyone's
already dead and I'm your back to your
friends our lives I'll kill them or you
will eat the zombie meat and or you
would eat nothing no you're not allowed
to eat nothing aptitude I'm nothing not
fair you no idea what answers question
faster cake done yes as we go to the
second cupcake I don't know what to do
though I'm gonna make a unicorn unicorn
what like an evil unicorn I want to eat
a piece of sami bacon I'll tell you
honest mmm
I'm trying to make a brain it's kind of
hard my have Halloweeny because they're
just gruesome and messy and yours are
Halloween is has a very detailed and
like jerks okay I love this one I can't
not he's got a biscuit whiskers seasoned
with cumin citizen yes would you care to
tell me what
but bad it is a phone it's all I'm
saying with an unfortunate places okay
it's your phone okay I think I'm low
second cupcake done yes cool got it all
day so these are the final products
don't they look scrumptious thank you so
what did you make this is an eye and I
decided to make the whole cupcake and I
so the whole cupcake is ice and you know
when you have just an eyeball you have
the little thing that attaches to the
inside of your head so I figured I've
made that too so it's like you've
literally ripped out an eyeball please
go ahead and just put it on the plate
right cool
what about the other guy I think it's
kind of like a zombie I don't really
know his eyes they're supposed to look
like so this is my version of zombie and
a part of his head is ripped off and you
can see the brains the bloody gosh she
brings his Tigers sticking out and it's
also kind of bloody in and it's great
why don't you go to Bob vomiting oh yeah
that's what it is
I thought you might be a vegetarian so
maybe eating oh so what did you make
okay so over here very dark play I've
got my Black Cauldron where I make all
of my spells and as you can see I've
make you concoction with body parts no
who's birds are those I can't tell you
you know I actually think that red looks
really good looks like it's really part
of the scene not just like that thank
you and this one is my gravestone the
r.i.p was really hard to make so I think
it says blob IP right now and then I've
got little vines that don't look like
vines from maybe spinach or vomit yeah
your your cupcake vomited on
great yeah that's what it is I've got
like pebbles outlined the grain and this
is supposed to be a hand coming out of
the grave
and this is there it is boom now it's
time for the real scary experience we
have to eat each other's cupcakes it's
wrong that I'm kind of excited butters
my spells taste glory good are you doing
this to me
I'm not doing anything look so gross Oh
mati this is that blob I keep try get
filthy try gets little fingers nice
ladylike
[Applause]
alright so I'm gonna eat your zombies
brain I don't know what that tastes like
so give me a detailed description of how
the zombie brain stood like a little
piece of hair in it I'm sorry yeah yeah
where his hair used to be so how come I
get you feel like you're starting to
turn into a zombie no actually it was
pretty nice it was yeah I think I'm so
glad I didn't have to eat mine now the
the extra dirty the extra messy eyeball
that I can't even pick up without
fitting everything I seen my fingers I
want you to take a bite so big you're
gonna bite into the iris okay oh my god
[Music]
now it's your turn it looks really good
good good you look you do look like you
just eat let's go out or something like
white makeup yeah mmm sounds beware that
was our attempt at making really spooky
Halloween cupcakes hope you liked it and
let me know down in the comments who you
think won at the DX touch or me
check out the exit is channel where we
have pumpkins that'll be interesting to
some of our artistic skills we obviously
did an amazing job so
go check it out this bump to myself what
do that I have a spooky day or evening
bye
I got dark cream okay I got light green
with speckles mm-hmm damn I love booger
are you definitely booger my face very
good it's watermelon the boo goo is not
you thought this may be I swear I don't
taste like